Welcome back.
Couple of quick announcements.
Okay, it's
uh
Your second quiz is a week from today.
And then things are going to come
rolling at you really fast because 2
weeks after that is the third quiz, and
2 weeks after that is the last day of
class, the project is due.
And as I said in my email yesterday,
which some of you might have read, your
final exam is scheduled for the Monday
of the following week, 12th.
I know that some of you have travel
plans, and you are trying to juggle
things because you need to make your
plane reservations or you already have.
So, I offered the choice of
you know, having the exam online. The
exam will be in the same time, 10:15 to
12:15, I think, on Monday.
But you could take it virtually wherever
you are in the world on Brightspace. So,
the trade-off will be it'll become a
multiple-choice exam. There is no way in
which physically I can do a regular exam
in Brightspace and grade it from, you
know,
from the inputs you turn in. So, it'll
be multiple choice, which has plusses
and minuses. The right answer will be
one of the choices,
but there will be no partial credit. So,
I will let you think about it, and I
mean, I'm okay with either choice, but
if we decide to go with the online, I
will make that choice, and then you
don't have to you can do whatever you
want in that in that last week of class.
But the the second and third quizzes
will be in person, the project is due on
the last day of class.
So, think about it. On Wednesday, I'll
kind of, you know, any of any of you
feel strongly that you have to take it
physically, then let me know so that,
you know, you'd prefer to do it. I don't
know why you would want to do it
physically, but if you do, let me know.
You know, and I will find a way to
accommodate you.
So, let's get started on the second
stretch of this class. I mean, we've
talked about the investment principle,
right? All of this class so far. Come up
with a way of estimating hurdle rates,
cost of capital, weighted average of
your cost of equity and your cost of
debt. And we compare that to the returns
you make on your pro- on whatever
investment you're looking at. Those
returns can be based on accounting
numbers, accounting returns,
or based on cash flows, incremental cash
flows, net present value, and
So, as you look back, those are the
building blocks for corporate finance.
Today, we're going to start on the
second element, which is the choice
between debt and equity that every
business has to make. Should I borrow
money? Should I use my own money? Small
or large, every business has to make
this choice. And before we delve into
the trade-off, the financial trade-off
that determines whether you should
borrow money,
let's put something on the table. Debt
has this mixed effect on us, right? It's
not just a financial decision. There's a
moral taint associated
with borrowing money.
In many religions, for a long time,
borrowing money was viewed as a sin, and
lending money was viewed as an even
bigger sin.
So, debt comes with this combination.
There's a financial aspect and an
emotional aspect. So, when people say,
"I don't want to borrow money,"
sometimes that decision is not coming
from the financial aspect. It's, "Hey,
debt makes me feel worried. Debt is not
something that I I can live with."
So, with that in the background, let's
talk a little bit about the two basic
questions we're going to look at this in
this stretch. First, we're going to look
at is there a mix of debt and equity
that's right for my company? Notice how
I phrased it. It's not is there a mix of
debt and equity that's right for every
company, but is there a mix of debt and
equity that's right for my company?
And you're going to see two views. One
says there is no such mix, that looking
for it is, you know, just an exercise in
futility. The other says there is a mix,
and let's come up with that mix. So,
we'll start with that, the trade-off
between debt and equity, and what might
determine whether you borrow money or
use your own money.
The other question we have to examine is
what kind of debt is right for me.
Assuming you decide to borrow money,
long-term or short-term, fixed rate or
floating rate, US dollar, euro, or
pesos.
So, those are the questions we're going
to start with. So, let's start with the
question of debt versus equity. Before
we
examine that question, let's first lay
out what separates debt from equity.
You're saying that's easy. Let's go to
the balance sheet, check out what's
called debt and equity. What do you see?
We saw in our cost of capital discussion
that doesn't always answer the question.
So, here are the dividing lines.
With debt, you get a fixed or a
contractual claim on the cash flows.
In most parts of the world, and we'll
talk about what parts of the world this
is not true, debt claimed interest
expense is tax deductible.
If the company gets into financial
trouble, you get first priority on the
cash flows. So, if you liquidate, you
get the first claim in the cash flows.
In general, most cases, debt comes with
a finite maturity.
It could be very long, but it's a finite
maturity. And in general, if your firm
is healthy, lenders don't take a role in
how the company is run. We'll talk about
what happens when you fall into
distress, but if you lend money to a
firm, you're not involved in how the
company picks projects, you know, how
much it pays in dividends, which can be
a problem for you as a lender.
At the other end of the spectrum, you
have equity.
Equity also entitles you to a cash flow
claim, but it's a residual claim. It's
whatever's left over. It's not a
contractual claim. You cannot sue a
company for not paying dividends. You
can put pressure on it, but you can't
sue it. Second, in much of the world,
it's not tax deductible. Again, I'll
talk about the exceptions, but cash
flows to equity have to come out of
after-tax cash flows.
Third,
if the company gets into financial
trouble, you're the last person in line.
If there is anything left over, and
there might be nothing,
you get whatever's left over.
In general, equity does not come with a
finite life. So, when you look at a
common stock, it doesn't say expires in
20 years or 25 years. It goes on. And
finally, you get to run the company.
So, when you look look at a balance
sheet, don't look at what something's
called. Think about, "Hey, where does it
fall in this spectrum?"
We'll also talk about hybrid securities.
Hybrid securities have a mix of debt and
equity. We kind of mentioned them in the
context of cost of capital.
They share some of the features of debt
and some of the features of equity.
Convertible debt.
The debt portion looks very much like
that. There's a coupon rate, there's a
face value, there's a maturity. But
there's also an option to convert into
equity if the stock price goes up
enough. That's the equity portion. Your
preferred stock
looks like debt in terms of fixed
dividend,
but unlike that, it's not tax
deductible. So, there's a little bit of
equity in it. And finally, there are
bonds which have options linked into
them where the portion of the bond can
potentially be equity.
So, with that set up, let's talk a
little bit about how the world looks in
terms of the use of debt and equity.
When you think about debt, you know, you
borrow money, you take on bank loans or
corporate bonds. We can look at the the
choices there. But with equity, the most
common way in which companies invest
equity back is through retained
earnings.
Retained earnings belong to the equity
investors. So, if you look across the
world, I've broken out what percentage,
and this was in 2024, what percentage of
the financing in 2024 came from net
debt. You're saying, "What do you mean
net debt?" Debt issuances minus debt
repayments, right? So, that's the net
debt. How much from equity issuances?
These are new equity issuances made by
companies, and how much from retained
earnings. And you can see the variation.
If you look at India and the EU, a very
high percentage
and Japan as well, a very high
percentage of the financing came from
retained earnings.
Now, we can make of it later as we talk
about the choices that we can talk about
why that might be. The highest
dependence net debt, the US has a lot of
net debt, China has a lot of net debt.
So, you can see that across the world
there's a variation in where companies
go to raise money.
Now, hold on to the chart because as we
talk about the trade-off, maybe we can
explain the differences across the
regions.
Now, as we look at this choice though,
you're going to see one thing show up as
we look across companies.
Well, across the world companies borrow
money, in the US you'll have a much
greater dependence on the corporate bond
market in the rest of the world. 30
years ago, it was entirely the US that
had corporate bonds. The rest of the
world, including Europe and Asia, was
all bank and clothes.
But in the US you always had this choice
of corporate bonds. Until the early
1980s in the US, only highly rated
companies, investment grade companies,
could issue bonds.
If you fell below, then you lost the
capacity to go to the bond market. Until
a guy called Mike Milken and Drexel
Burnham changed the rules on that.
What they did was they did not create
the junk bond market. Junk bonds had
always been there. But they allowed
companies with junk bond status to issue
bonds to the market saying, "If you pay
a high enough interest rates, people
will buy the bonds."
So, corporate bonds have always been a
choice for US companies. Of course, US
companies can still go to banks to
borrow money.
But as you look at the companies at our
at our non-US companies, you Vale, Tata
Motors, you're going to see them use
more corporate bonds than before. So,
across the world you're starting to see
the doors open to the use of corporate
bonds. So, I'm going to start with the
question.
Let's say you're a company, you can
issue corporate bonds or you can take
bank loans.
Why might you choose one over the other?
Give me an argument for either side. Why
might you use corporate bonds or bank
loans? France?
Sorry?
Could be cheaper, but that would be
tough to sustain, right? Which one is
going to be cheaper, you think?
If it's cheaper, then it has to be good
reason, right? Why might a bank loan be
cheaper? Why might a bank lend to you to
lower rate?
It's but corporate bonds can also be
secured, right? So, let's say there's
security out. Can banks ask you for more
information, private information, before
they lend you money? Yeah? So, in a
sense, that might be one reason a bank
loan might be cheaper is you can show
them things you can't show the market
and say, "Hey, look, we have the cash
flows, we have the assets." So, for some
companies which have proprietary
information that they cannot reveal to
the market, a bank loan might be
cheaper.
In other cases though, a corporate bond
might be cheaper. But why? Because banks
have their own structures on how they
can lend money. They're rigid, they have
these rules. A corporate bond market
might not have to deal with those rules,
so corporate bond might be cheaper. So,
across the world this choice can be
driven by cheapness. What else?
Might drive you to one over the other.
When you borrow money from a bank, it
usually comes with restrictions called
covenants. The covenants can be very
onerous. You can't do this, you can't do
this. Corporate bonds tend to be lighter
on the covenant component. They have the
restrictions, but they're much looser.
So, if you're a company that doesn't
like to be restricted, the corporate
bond market might be better for you than
the bank loan market.
Third, when you go to a bank and you ask
for a loan, the bank has a structure of
loans, right? It says, "These are the
four types of loans we offer. Which one
would you like?" And you say, "Look, I'd
like this fifth type that I'd like to
create for me." The bank is going to
say, "No way."
Banks can't create innovative
securities. Corporate bond markets can.
We're going to talk about some of the
innovations that corporate bond markets
have created, specifically structured at
companies.
One is not automatically better than the
other. That's why companies often end up
using both. So, Disney for instance, has
most of its debt in corporate bonds, but
it still has a bank loan component. My
wager is that many of those bank loans
are tied to, you know, the land that
they own in Anaheim, that a bank might
be more the easy to approach and borrow
money on, take a mortgage loan. So, it
might vary even within companies as to
which one you pick.
So, with that lead-in, let's take a look
at what our companies have in terms of
types of debt.
First, I've broken down debt First, I've
listed out the total debt that they have
both in book value and market value
terms. That's a carryover from what we
did for the cost of capital component,
where I took the book value of debt and
convert to market value.
So, book value of debt, market value of
debt. Because this was 2013, I had to do
the lease debt myself.
Today, you can get the lease debt
directly
from your from your balance sheet.
If you look at the breakdown between
bonds and bank debt, Disney's about 92%
corporate bonds, 8% bank debt.
Most of its debt. But if you take a look
at Vale and Tata Motors, you can see how
this is starting to spread around the
world. Indian companies now have an
Indian bond market. European companies
have a Euro bond market.
Right?
Baidu, all of its debt is bank debt.
If you look at the structure of the
debt, Disney's debt is pretty much
short-term, you know,
1 to 5 years. But if you look at Vale,
much more long-term debt. Already, I
want you to start thinking about what is
it about Vale's assets that might lead
it to have much more long-term debt than
Disney's typical investments.
If you look at Tata Motors, its debt is
you know, Tata Motors and Baidu are more
short- and medium-term debt as well. If
you look at the domestic versus foreign
currency, Disney has about 94 and 1/2%
US dollar debt. Do you remember how much
of its revenues came from outside the US
way back?
Give me a guess. Do you
It was about It was 18% of their
revenues came from outside. Already you
can see a mismatch, right? If 18% of
your revenues come from outside the US,
why is only 4 and 1/2% debt? We'll come
back and examine why that might be.
Right?
For Vale, much of its debt is foreign
currency debt.
Again, we already have a reason for
seeing why, right? What does Vale do?
It's a mining company. When you're a
mining company, you sell your stuff into
a dollar market, your revenues will tend
to be in dollars. Not surprisingly, a
lot of their debt is dollar debt.
If you look at Tata Motors, about 29% of
its debt is foreign currency debt. I'll
wager almost all of that debt is with
Jaguar Land Rover, not with Tata Motors
domestically. And finally, if you look
at Baidu, 82% of its debt
is foreign currency debt.
Remember the question I asked at the
start of the class, I said, "How many of
you have used Baidu?"
And the answer was like three people.
Mostly from China.
Because if you're outside China, you've
never used Baidu. Almost all of their
revenues are from China. And already you
can see a mismatch opening up. So, one
of the things we're going to talk about
is why do companies sometimes mismatch
debt? And if you have a mismatch, what
do you have to do as management to take
take care of that mismatch?
Finally, in terms of fixed and floating
rate debt, Vale and Tata Motors, it's
all fixed rate debt.
Now,
Disney and Baidu have a small percentage
of floating rate debt. Does everybody
know how floating rate debt works? Fixed
rate debt, you take a 10-year loan, the
interest rate is set up front.
Floating rate debt is very much like an
adjustable rate mortgage. Every year the
interest rate gets reset. Used to be to
LIBOR, but since LIBOR has lost its
allure, it's to a Treasury rate or some
market-set rate.
So, basically, every year the rate can
go up and down, which can be a plus
or a minus, right? If you're a borrower,
it can be a plus plus if the rates go
down, the rates get reset. It can be a
minus if rates went up is it okay for a
company to go borrow money on a floating
rate debt rather than a fixed rate debt.
Now, before we start in the trade-off,
there's a very simple way to see what
what the right debt mix is for you based
on where you are in the life cycle. So,
remember the corporate life cycle,
you're a startup or a young company.
What kind of income do you have?
Usually, you're losing money, your cash
flows are negative. You shouldn't be
borrowing money. It doesn't make sense
to borrow money for two reasons. One is
you get no tax advantages. Two, you're
taking your growth assets and putting
them at risk for what? So, when you're a
young company, your focus should be
almost entirely on equity or equity
hybrids.
That's why I've never even understood
the notion of venture capital debt.
There is this business in Silicon
Valley. It doesn't even make sense. The
only way it makes sense is the debt is
being if it's equity disguised as debt.
It's convertible debt with almost all of
the value coming from the conversion.
Because you really shouldn't be
borrowing money. As you move into high
growth, convertible debt will start to
show its presence. Because now you have
enough income to cover interest
expenses, but you still have little
income relative to your market value.
And then as you get more mature,
conventional debt will start to show up
your your debt mix will start to
will become large. You can borrow more
money.
And eventually when you go into decline,
you got to bring your debt down as you
become a smaller firm. Otherwise, you're
going to go into distress.
You tell me where your company is in the
life cycle. And I want you to think
about your company. Do you remember your
company? Go back and look at the master
list, it's there, right? Ask yourself
where in the life cycle is that company?
Already you can start to see whether
your company should have a lot of debt.
It's amazing how much that explains why
companies have the debt that they do.
Now, as you go through the life cycle,
there are these transition points. I
call them bar mitzvah moments where
essentially you get to a point where you
say, "Hey, I'm not that kind of company
anymore." Right?
So, these transition moments basically
the
initially as a as a private business
with potential the first transition
moment is you approach a venture
capitalist. You're getting somebody
else's money
to get this process set. So, already you
can see that transition involves some
pain. You're giving up a piece of your
company in return for an equity
investment.
Now, as the company gets bigger, there
will be a point where venture capital
alone is not enough. That point is later
than it used to be. 40 years ago you hit
that point very quickly. Apple and
Microsoft had to go public a lot sooner
than Uber did
cuz you didn't have the access to other
sources of equity beyond venture
capital.
So, when you go public, a second
transition point. Transition point is is
now you're approaching public markets
for equity. You're saying, "How is it
any different from venture capital
equity?" You're playing a different
game. You got to learn that game. In
addition,
you also have to make your information
public. No, you got to disclose the
information. You have disclosure
requirements. Second transition point.
The third transition point is you're now
a public company, you need more capital.
It's called seasoned offerings. You can
either raise new equity or new debt.
Each of these transitions happen at some
point in a company's life. And each
transition is painful to get through
because it it makes you a different
company. You got to behave differently.
Now, as we approach look at this mix of
debt and equity, I want to lay some
definitions on the table so you're not
confused. When I talk about debt ratios,
I'm talking about debt to capital.
If I want to say debt to equity, I'll be
very specific about debt to equity. So,
debt ratio to me is just debt to capital
which is debt divided by debt plus
equity.
Usually when I'm talking about debt
ratios, I'm talking about market value.
So, if I want to say book value, I will
specifically say book value.
So, that's just to save myself the pain
of having to fully explain what the debt
ratio is each time. So, debt ratio is a
market value debt to capital ratio for
much of this discussion. Right?
Now, within that context though, my
definition of debt is all
interest-bearing debt and lease
commitments. And the reason I'm explicit
about that is at least for the 2013
numbers, I had to bring the lease
commitments on.
So, my debt includes all of those. It
does not include supplier credit,
accounts payable, etc. the
non-interest-bearing debt on your
balance sheet.
And finally, when I talk about equity,
it will be the market value of equity.
Share price times number of shares. So,
effectively it'll change on a day-to-day
basis and the debt ratio will change as
well.
So, here's the basic trade-off that I
want to talk about. First is you got
debt, you got equity.
There are pluses and minuses to both.
What are the advantages of using debt?
So, I'll focus on the debt side because
that'll give you the flip side equity.
What are the benefits of using debt?
And what are the costs of using debt?
Right?
And along the way we'll see if in fact
there is a right mix of debt and equity.
So, before I even show you the
trade-off, what is the biggest single
benefit of using debt?
Franz?
It is tax savings. Right?
But if you ask most CFOs why they use
debt, that's not going to come up in the
conversation until later in the process.
So, I'm going to start with what I call
the illusory reasons people give for
using debt
or not using debt. Let's start with the
first one. That if you use debt to fund
an investment, you will generally earn a
higher return equity.
Is that true?
And generally that's true.
Why? Because you've less equity placed
in real estate for instance, the less
equity invested in something and the
more debt you use. As long as the return
you're making on the asset exceeds the
interest rate, the more you borrow, the
higher return equity is going to be.
That's good, right?
But when you borrow money, you also make
yourself a riskier company. In what
sense? Remember we talked about levered
and unlevered betas? As you borrow
money, your levered beta which tells you
what your cost of equity will be will go
up. So, the reason this is an illusion,
it's true you have a higher return
equity with more debt, but you'll also
have a higher cost of equity.
In fact, if you take a project where the
return equity is equal to the cost of
equity with no debt, levering it up will
not change the basic characters. It'll
still be a neutral project. A bad
project should not become a good project
just because you used debt.
A higher return equity comes with a
higher cost of equity.
Any questions on that? Right?
Second,
and this is something I hear all the
time. Debt is cheaper than equity.
Again, is that true on the face of it?
Yes, it'll always be true. Why? Because
the debt guy is in front of the line
ahead of you, right? So, if if you as an
equity investor are you know, if the
debt investor is charging 10%, you as
the equity investor will charge 12%,
14%. So, it's true. Debt is cheaper than
equity. This settles it, right? Debt is
cheaper than equity.
We should just use all debt.
And here's the catch, sir.
As you borrow money, it's true debt is
cheaper than equity at every step, but
it also makes both your equity and your
debt riskier and by doing so it pushes
up the cost of both. One of the things
we're going to see in the trade-off is
the effect of borrowing money. As you
borrow money, initially cheaper debt
replaces more expensive equity, your
cost of capital might go down. But as
both get pushed up, there will be a
tipping point where if you add that
additional dollar of debt, your cost of
capital starts to go up again.
So, when your CFO said debt is cheaper
than equity, they're giving you half of
the story. You got also think about the
effect it has on the risk of equity and
the risk of debt and it by itself is not
enough
to convince you to borrow money and
lower your cost of capital.
So, this is the two illusory reasons
I've heard for, "Hey, let's use debt
instead of equity."
I've also also two reasons why companies
refuse to borrow money.
One is if you borrow money, you will
have lower net income.
Again, is that true?
For any given operating income, when I
borrow money, what happens? I have more
interest expenses, more interest
expenses, lower net income. Lower net
income is bad, right?
What's the missing piece here?
What are you measuring that net income
against? What did I invest as an equity
investor? As you borrow money, there's
less equity invested. This is the flip
side of the return equity story. We're
missing the denominator.
So, it's true borrowing money always
lowers net income, but you have far less
equity invested in the company as well.
And here's a final pushback you get
against use of debt. If you borrow more
money, your default risk will increase
and if you're rated, your bond rating
will generally come under pressure.
Perhaps even go down.
Again, technically true, right?
As you borrow more money, S&P and
Moody's are going to start freaking out.
They're going to start to lower your
ratings.
But are lower ratings or higher ratings
always better than lower ratings?
Would you rather have a triple A or a
triple B? The answer is of course I'd
like to have a triple A. What if the
only way you can have a triple A is by
never borrowing money? Would you rather
have a triple A where you can't borrow
money or a single A where you borrow
$100 billion? I'd take the single A with
$100 billion cuz I get the tax benefits
of debt.
If your objective is to maximize net
income at the highest rating possible,
of course you should never borrow money.
And there are companies out there that
do it.
There are some transient reasons though
why you might choose to use debt
as opposed to equity or equity as
opposed to it. I'm going to call them
transient because they will pass.
Let's say you have your your stock price
has been pushed up too high.
Say you're Nvidia. Your market cap is
3.3 trillion and internally as Jensen
Huang you say, "Look, this is crazy.
We're worth about 2 trillion, the
market's given us a $3.3 trillion
market cap." Do you see how this might
affect your choice of debt or equity?
If you think your equity is overpriced,
what are you going to tend to use to do
your next acquisition, to take your next
project?
You're probably going to use equity
because it's being overpriced.
Conversely, let's say you should really
be a triple B rated company and S&P is
giving you a double A rating.
You might choose to borrow money even
though you don't need the money because
you're being
So, that's a transient factor that
companies sometimes exploit. You know,
so the illusory and the transient
reasons are always floating around. That
might explain why companies sometimes do
things that you don't that you can't
explain away.
But those are the illusory and transient
reasons. But let's talk about the real
reasons, the real trade-off on debt
versus equity.
The biggest benefit of borrowing money
and Franz mentioned this is a tax
benefit.
In fact, it is the government that you
should blame the most when you talk
about leverage.
We talk about what form the tax benefit
takes, but we'll also talk about why the
tax benefit might vary across countries
and markets.
There's a second reason
for borrowing money and it's it's a
strange one. There are some companies
where borrowing money can make the
company more disciplined in the way it
takes projects. Let that No, go on the
pan for a little while. We'll come back
and look at how debt might make some
managers more disciplined.
So, the two biggest benefits of debt.
They have to be paid off against three
three costs that come with borrowing
money. The first is when you borrow
money, I don't care who you are. You
could be Apple or Microsoft, got to be
immense amount of income. Borrowing
money always increases the likelihood
of default.
You think, "But I'm with Apple." It
might go up from 0.01% to 0.02%, but it
always goes up. Borrowing money will
always increase your expected bankruptcy
cost. We'll have to come back and be
more explicit about what that
probability is and what that cost is
that we're multiplying to get the
expected bankruptcy cost. But, that's
the first and biggest cost. In fact, if
you wanted me to boil it down to basics,
it's tax benefits versus bankruptcy
cost. Those are the two biggest factors.
But, there are two secondary factors.
The first of the secondary factors is an
agency cost. What's an agency cost? An
agency cost arises when you have two
groups with very different interests.
The context of debt and equity, you see
what those very different interests are?
If you're a lender to a firm, you want
safety. You want cash flows. You don't
want the company to take risk because
you get no upside. If you're an equity
investor, your incentives are very
different. You want get upside. You want
to get those high returns.
Those agency costs will show up as
costs, usually on the borrower, and
we'll talk about what costs those will
take.
And finally,
when you borrow money,
you're giving up some future
flexibility. It's nice to have debt
capacity in case you need it. Right? In
case there's a recession, in case
there's a downturn, in case you have a
bad year, in case COVID hits.
Those are the three
costs, and that trade-off is going to
determine whether you should borrow
money or not. So, let's start with these
trade-offs before we look at explicit
ways of coming out the debt books.
The tax benefit of debt comes from a
very simple part of the tax code.
I haven't filed my taxes yet.
I always put it off till the last
moment, time value of money factors.
But, it's really because I don't like to
do my taxes.
But, we know how interest expenses play
out in taxes, which is if you have
income,
and that's key. You have to have income.
You have interest expense, you can claim
the interest expense as a tax deduction.
More difficult at the personal level
because there are all kinds of
constraints now on how how much you can
claim, but as a company, if you have
interest expense, you can claim it as a
tax benefit. And the tax benefit then
becomes that interest expense times the
tax rate you'd have paid
on the income.
In general, because interest expenses
save you taxes at the margin, the tax
rate you should be using is the marginal
tax rate. This is basically where we use
that marginal tax rate to come up with
the after-tax cost of debt.
So, at the the risk of stating the
obvious, a higher marginal tax rate,
the greater the tax benefit to borrowing
money.
So, across countries, when you compare
marginal tax rates, countries with
higher marginal tax rates are in effect,
you know, encouraging their companies to
borrow more money than company countries
with lower marginal tax rates.
So, the marginal tax rate is what
determines how much you can borrow.
So, with that in place, let's talk about
the effect
of this particular aspect
of the tax code on how much companies
borrow.
In the US, real estate, at least
publicly traded real estate can be
structured either as a corporation,
which is a more traditional structure
where you have income, you pay taxes,
or as real estate investment trusts.
Real estate investment trusts were
created by a congressional act in the
1970s.
And they come with very severe
strictures in what you can do. First, if
you're a REIT,
you can invest only in real estate. You
can't invest in technology, AI, you
can't, you know. Second,
you have to pay 95%
of your earnings
as dividends.
Might be 90%, but a very high percentage
of your earnings as dividends, right?
You think, "Why would I want to do
that?"
In return, you pay no corporate taxes.
So, file that away. REITs pay no
corporate taxes, so their marginal
corporate tax rate is zero. Real Real
estate corporations pay a more
traditional corporate tax rate, 21% plus
state and local taxes, maybe 25, 26%.
This might seem like a slam dunk, but
let's see if it is. If, given what I've
told you in terms of the tax benefits of
debt,
which of these two entities should have
more debt, real estate corporations or
REITs?
Seems like it should be real estate
corporations, right? But, what's the one
thing that allows the IRS to
do this and still collect taxes? What
did I say
these companies are required to do with
their earnings?
Pay 95%
as dividends. Let's say that the people
owning REITs tend to be high tax
individuals. If If that were the case,
you see how the IRS collects its taxes
anyway? The marginal tax rate there is
not the marginal tax rate of the
company, but the marginal tax rate of
the investors in the company.
Trust me, there's nothing that the
government gives away for free.
In this case, they're going to collect
their taxes one way or the other. The
way
that taxpayers get back at this is if
pension funds buy REITs,
then the IRS is cooked, right? Because
you can't collect taxes from the
company, you can't collect taxes on
pension funds.
So, we'll talk later about dividend
clientele, and guess what kinds of
investors tend to buy REITs the most.
Low tax rate or non-tax-paying
individuals
because that's where you get the
benefits of collecting. And there you
could argue REITs should be very lightly
levered because their investors are not
being taxed, the marginal tax rate is
close to zero.
So, we're going to look at marginal tax
rates. But, let's stay on this theme,
though. All right, let's look at
airlines around the world. You got
Ryanair, an Irish airline. You got
Lufthansa. You got, you know,
you got the US airlines. If you compare
the debt ratios across the airlines,
and you can do it after class on Capital
IQ if you want.
Given what we said about marginal tax
rates, which of these airlines should
have the lowest debt ratio?
Where's Ryanair located again?
Ireland. What's Ireland's one claim to
economic fame?
It's a tax rate, right? I mean, it's not
technological prowess. It's not I love
Dublin as a city, but without the 12%
tax rate, I'm not sure companies would
be flocking there.
It's a 12% tax rate. You have the one of
the You have the lowest corporate tax
rate of any country in the U-zone,
and probably any major, you know, any
country where these companies are
located. Ryanair should have the lowest
debt ratio. You can go check it out if
that is the case, but you'd expect it to
have the least
debt because it gets a lower tax
benefit.
So, as you look at tax rates, that's
going to play out in how much you decide
to borrow.
So, already you know that there's stock.
I mean, so we'll talk a little bit about
this, but in 2017,
the US had the highest marginal
corporate tax rate in the world at 40%.
It had the most dysfunctional tax
system. And here's why. The marginal tax
rate was 40%, the effective tax rate was
21%. So, companies found a way to pay
less than average taxes.
But, guess what they collected as a tax
benefit of debt? It's a dysfunctional
system because companies borrow a lot,
and they're not paying much in taxes.
And one of the things that that that the
2017 tax law did was it brought that 35%
federal corporate tax rate
down to 21%.
Right? So, holding all else constant,
assuming that that is the one thing that
changed. It came with a variety of other
changes as well.
What should happen to debt ratios after
this tax change?
They should go down, right? We have less
tax benefit. I've been tracking the
dollar debt, and I'll show you that that
table later.
The dollar debt in the US has dropped a
little bit. The debt ratios, debt to
EBITDA, is much lower than it used to
be, but there hasn't been a steep
drop-off in the use of debt.
And that's a little bit of a mystery
because you're going to say, "Why aren't
companies reacting more?" Part of it
could be inertia. They do what they've
always done. Part of it is me-tooism,
which is everybody else borrows, so
we're going to continue to borrow. But,
holding all else constant, you should
have seen a much bigger drop-off in debt
after 2017
than you did.
And
now we'll see if there's there's more
corporate tax cuts coming,
but the effective tax rate didn't change
it by that much after the 2017. It went
from 21% to 19%. So, a big drop in the
marginal tax rate translated into a 2%
drop in the effective tax rates.
Let's talk about the second reason
companies might be asked to borrow
money.
Let's say you're the manager of a mature
company. You have lots of earnings, big
positive cash flows.
You have a tendency to get lazy. Why?
Because we take a bad project, who's
going to notice? You hide it. Coca-Cola
takes a bad project, it you know, it
introduces a new beverage that doesn't
work, you hide it in the cash flows,
people don't even notice.
You have a tendency to get lazy and
sloppy.
So, here's what I'm going to try to do.
I'm going to try to get you to borrow
money. You're saying, "Why would that
make me less lazy and sloppy?" Because
now
you have interest expenses to make and
if you take a bad project, it could have
personal consequences. I'm trying to
make you feel the pain.
And the pain here will be if you take
bad project. I call this the Volvo
argument for that. Let me explain why.
Let's say it's 5 years out. You've
joined an investment bank, a hedge fund.
You bought a house in the suburbs.
You got two dogs, two cats, two spouses,
whatever. And two cars.
And every day you take the train into
work.
You have two cars, let me be more
explicit. The first car
is a Volvo 960 extra armor. The one you
know the one with side airbags. It's
like driving a tank around town.
Your second car is some kind of a tin
trap. I don't want to insult any of your
cars.
But let's say it's a old Yugo. You found
it at a scrapyard somewhere.
It shakes while you drive it. You go on
the freeway, things start flying off it.
So basically it's a
The first day
is your lucky day. You drive your Volvo
into the train station. You park at 7:00
in the morning. You get on the train.
You come into New York. You work all
day. You work all evening. You work all
night. That's how you afford the two
spouses and the two dogs and the two
cars.
10:00 at night, you get off the train.
You drag yourself to the car. You're
exhausted.
And you live only 5 minutes away from
the train station. But between the train
station and your house, there's a
traffic light. You get up to the top of
the hill, the light turns red. You say,
"Oh drat." I'm censoring as I'm going
along. Those would not be the exact
curse words you use. But as you sit
there watching the red light, illegal
thoughts start to cross your mind.
You say, "What if I run this red light?"
Now, there are two things you worry
about running red lights. One is
getting a ticket. But these are the
suburbs. At 10:00 at night, the police
have all gone home.
The other is getting hit. And then you
remember you're in your Volvo extra
armor. If somebody hits you, you get a
little dent on the side. The other guy's
all crumpled up. You don't care. You
drive
through the red lights back home, all
safe. Next day, you repeat the process,
but today you're in your Yugo.
You pull up to the So, you work all day,
work all night. 10:00 at night, you pull
up to the top of the hill again, the
light turns red. It's like a conspiracy
again.
And as you watch that red light, you
think about doing what you did
yesterday, but you suddenly remember
you're not in your Volvo. You're in your
Yugo. You say, "What am I thinking?
Bicyclist comes along and hits me, I
could roll off the road here."
And let me pull up. You're saying,
"What's this got to do with good
projects and bad projects?"
Think of the the Volvo as a as a all
equity funded company with lots of cash
cushions. And think of the red light as
a bad project. Why do you run the red
light? Because I protected you so well
that you really didn't care.
Think of the Yugo as the same company
stripped off its cash.
And even stripped off its airbags. And
think of why you stop. Because you're
afraid of getting hurt. It's an extreme
argument for the use of debt.
But you can see why it gets made at some
companies.
It's called the Jensen free cash flow
argument for debt. Does that name sound
familiar?
Jensen's Alpha. He likes attaching his
name to whatever he does. Lives on
forever.
Some argument that he made in the 1980s
for leveraged buyouts. He said, "That's
the reason we see leveraged buyouts.
It's because you see mature companies
lots of cash flows. Borrowing money
forces them to be more accountable."
But I never quite bought the argument
for leveraged buyouts, right? Because
that's not just borrowing money, it's
borrowing way too much money.
So, somewhere between the Volvo and that
extreme debt, there is a happy
compromise. You borrow just enough
to make managers accountable. And maybe
it'll work.
So, let's take this argument. Let's see
what kinds of companies then should be
forced to borrow money or put pressure
on to borrow money. So, there are three
companies all lightly funded with debt.
So, conservatively financed means mostly
funded with equity. The first is a
privately owned business. The second are
publicly traded companies where the
shareholding is dispersed. Lots of
shareholders each owning a small stake.
And the third is a publicly traded
company with activist investors, a Carl
Icahn or a Bill Ackman in the midst.
In which of these three groups of
companies will debt act as a mechanism
for disciplining management the most?
Let's think one by one. If you're a
owner of a a private business
and you say, "I need to take on debt
to be more disciplined in the way I run
the business." You're in big trouble
already, right? It's your money. And why
are you taking bad projects? So,
obviously a private business, the
discipline argument doesn't get very
far.
So, among the other two, B and C, which
group should be the one that's induced
to borrow money? Because
C already has an activist looking over
the shoulder. So, if a manager takes a
bad project, Carl Icahn is going to jump
down his throat, right?
So, in C, you don't need that to make
you disciplined. Those activist
investors will keep you in line. It's
exactly where there's nobody watching
the store
where you essentially are going to try
to force the company to borrow money.
The Krafts, the Heinzes, the Coca-Colas
of the world
might be better off borrowing more money
and being run differently because of
that borrowed money.
So, tax benefits, added discipline.
Let's talk about the biggest single cost
you have to worry about when you borrow
money. It's an expected bankruptcy cost.
There are two ingredients that go into
bank- expected bankruptcy costs. The
first is the probability that you will
go bankrupt, which always rises as you
have more debt for every company.
The second is the cost of going
bankrupt.
Sounds like a stupid question. What's
the cost
of going bankrupt? What happens when you
go bankrupt?
File Chapter 11, which puts you where?
In the legal system.
Incredibly efficient system, right?
I remember, you know, in the 1990s when
I became a US citizen,
to show you how naive I was, 6 weeks
after I became a citizen, I got an
envelope in the mail inviting me to do
my civic duty.
You know what that invitation was? Well,
it's not really an invitation. It was an
invitation with jury duty. Show you how
naive I I was actually excited.
So, I show up like the day of jury duty
expecting balloons and a party, but this
bored-looking woman sitting behind a
table saying, "What do you want?" I'm
here for jury duty. So, go sit in that
chair.
What am I look What am I doing? Watch
that terminal. What am I looking for?
Your number.
So, what if my number doesn't come up?
You can come back again tomorrow.
So, I can't keep coming back every day.
So, we pay $10 a day. I said, "That
settles it. I'll come back for the rest
of my life." Gives you a little picture
into how much the legal system values
your time and my time,
but not Shay's time. Shay's a lawyer, so
I know. So, the the people in the system
basically, so
you're going to end up in that system
and it's going to suck you dry.
That's called a direct bankruptcy cost.
My second son went to work at um
Duff & Phelps and then at KPMG and this
is in 2021. I asked him, you know, "What
are you working on?" He said, "The
Lehman bankruptcy." I said, "The Lehman
bankruptcy?"
When did Lehman go bankrupt?
2008. 2021, they were still working on
the Lehman bankruptcy.
You know that 50% of Lehman's assets
went into legal costs?
That's a direct cost of bankruptcy. You
end up in that system, it basically
means a big chunk of your value is going
to disappear into all kinds of costs.
Time value of money not even considered.
That's a direct cost of bankruptcy. But
if that were the only cost, I would
actually encourage companies to borrow
more money. Because there's a second
cost that's
It's I think much more insidious.
If people think you're in trouble,
are you in trouble?
Tell me why. What is it about people
think you're in trouble? Your customers
think you're in trouble, what happens?
Would you buy a car from a company
that's triple C rated?
I'd be worried about getting spare parts
for the car, right?
Your customers stop buying your product,
especially if it's long term.
What about your suppliers? What do they
do if they think you're in trouble?
They expect cash. No 60 days for you.
Give me the cash now because I don't
know whether you'll be around in 60
days. What are your employees doing
every day?
Checking out LinkedIn saying, "Hey,
where do I get my next job?" I mean,
talk about being They're not exactly
sure they're going to have a job here.
Everything starts to unravel. There's
this Once you get into that that that
now we're in trouble, you can very
quickly spiral your way into actually
being in trouble.
In fact, in November of 2008, every
single investment bank was entering that
debt spiral. We forget this. We came
really close, not just losing Lehman,
but Morgan Stanley, Merrill Lynch, every
one of them was spiraling out.
I mean, we we luckily broke that spiral
in time, but there was a very real
chance it might not have been broken, in
which case six investment banks go out
at at the same time.
That system would the market would not
have been able to stay intact.
That's an indirect bankruptcy cost.
So, to total cost here is not just the
direct cost, but the indirect cost. And
I want to think about why that indirect
bankruptcy cost might be different
across different kinds of companies, cuz
that's going to determine what the
expected bankruptcy cost is.
So, firms with more volatile earnings
should borrow less than firms with more
stable earnings. Why? Cuz for any level
of earnings, you think about the
likelihood of bankruptcy, if your
earnings are much more unstable,
you should borrow less.
And finally, companies which have
greater indirect bankruptcy costs
should borrow less than companies with
more indirect bankruptcy costs.
I'm sorry. Companies more indirect
bankruptcy costs should borrow less than
companies with less indirect bankruptcy
costs.
So, let me give you three choices, three
businesses, and you tell me, based on
this bankruptcy cost discussion, which
of these three groups should have the
most debt, which should have the least
debt?
You got a grocery store,
an aircraft manufacturer, you can put a
name on it, Bombardier, Boeing, Embraer,
or a high-tech company. Again, you can
put your own name on it.
Meta, Apple.
Let's say they all have the same level
of earnings.
$10 billion in earnings. And you're
saying, which one of these companies
should borrow the most, which should
borrow the least, based on just the
bankruptcy cost question? Which one
should borrow the most?
Yes.
Tell me why.
Yeah?
Who who who
Yeah.
Have you ever walked in a grocery store
and said, I I walk into that Morton
Williams, hideously overpriced store at
the corner of Bleecker?
I've never stopped and asked, is this a
triple C rated grocery? Because frankly,
I'm not planning to bring the lettuce
back in 5 weeks, right? If you're a
customer of a grocery store, it doesn't
matter to you that the rating's low.
Grocery stores can sustain much higher
levels of debt and much lower ratings
and get away with it.
Cuz much of their sales is to customers
who don't care.
And their suppliers, it's basically 3 to
6 days anyway. It's not like you had a
huge amount of credit. Grocery stores
can borrow the most. But let's take
aircraft manufacturers versus technology
firms. There's this volatility of
earnings component, right? Let's hold
those the same. Let's suppose they're
both volatile.
Think about indirect bankruptcy costs.
What does a typical Boeing contract look
like?
10 years, 110 aircraft.
There is zero chance that Singapore Air
signs that contract if Boeing is a
double B rated company.
Right?
Because you need the aircraft delivered,
you want the spare parts.
For a For an aircraft maker, the
perception of trouble is almost
definitely trouble. That's why in March
23rd of 2000 2020, at the height of
COVID, Boeing came this close to
effectively going into receivership or
bankruptcy.
Cuz people thought, hey, what if they
don't make it?
So, for for an aircraft manufacturer,
the reason you want to be careful about
borrowing money is you go to that
tipping point, you very quickly can tip
into bankruptcy.
So, I would expect if you if you told me
to rank it, grocery stores to borrow the
most, air airplane manufacturers to
borrow less, and high-tech companies,
especially during the higher volatility
of earnings, to hold back on debt. Cuz
no high-tech company can count on its
earnings continuing for the long term.
You say, "Well, what if I'm Apple?"
Well, what if smartphones go out of
style?
There's Apple's value down the drain,
right?
So, if you're if any of you doing
high-tech companies, many of you do
computer companies, software companies,
don't be surprised to see really low
debt ratios, even if they have the
earnings to borrow a lot more money.
It's not that they're avoiding the tax
benefits of debt, it's that expected
bankruptcy cost for them, even with
their higher earnings, is much greater
than for a company that sells consumer
goods.
So, that's expected bankruptcy costs.
Let's talk about agency costs.
Any questions on bankruptcy costs?
Now, clearly, as you expand that
bankruptcy cost component, companies
borrow less and less. What if the
government comes in
and says, "We'll protect you against
bankruptcy" to companies. What do you
think companies are going to do?
They're going to borrow more money.
That's what happened in Korea in the
1990s, where the banks were told by the
government to lend money to the
chaebols, Korean holding companies,
saying, "Don't worry, we'll back up the
debt." And Korean companies were among
the most highly leveraged in the 1990s
before the whole system came apart in
1996.
Second, let's talk about agency costs.
Agency costs arises anytime you ask
somebody else to do something for you.
I'll give you my classic example of
agency costs. How many of you have kids?
I have four. They're now all grown up,
but I still remember when they were
younger,
hiring a babysitter is an exercise in
agency costs.
As you guys are the game at work, right?
You have to leave at 7:00, the
babysitter would arrive at 7:15, 15
minutes late.
And as you left, you gave very specific
instructions.
Make sure they eat dinner by 8:00. Make
sure they're in bed by 9:00. No candy,
no ice cream after 9:00.
And you leave.
9:00 rolls around, the babysitter is
watching Gossip Girls or whatever on TV.
The kids come down. They detect
weakness. Kids are good at sensing
weakness. They come down and say,
"We want ice cream." And she faces a
choice, or he faces a choice, which is,
"Should I fight them on this ice cream,
in which case I don't get to watch
Gossip Girls, or should I just give them
the ice cream?"
The choice is easy.
10:00 you come home.
The babysitter is in a hurry to leave.
You don't know why.
She collects her money, she's out of
there. And then you notice these
thudding noises upstairs. The kids are
bouncing off the walls.
And you learn a very important lesson,
which is never go out again.
There are two ways you deal with this
agency cost. One is what I call the
monitoring solution, which is you put
cameras all over your house,
and you watch your babysitter on a phone
while you're having dinner. She's
feeding them ice cream. You got to zap
them right now. No, maybe have electric
currents. That's a monitoring solution.
The other is you build in the cost into
your choices.
Let's take debt and equity, and let's
see how similar trade-off plays out. So,
you guys be the lenders, you're the
equity investors.
When equity investors come to borrow
money from you, and this is a game you
played earlier on, what do they tell you
their projects are safe or risky?
Very safe projects. I look after this
money just like it's my own.
You lend money to the firm
without any restrictions put on? You're
a trusting banker.
Now, the equity investor has your money,
no constraints, so guess what they're
going to do? Take much riskier projects
than the project they described to you.
For all you know, they might be at the
racetrack putting all your money down on
number 35.
If it wins, they get the upside. If it
doesn't, limited liability.
You can liquidate her assets, but you
have nothing.
They might borrow more, they might pay
dividends.
That's why as lenders, what do you do?
You put in restrictions. You can't do
this. You can't do this.
You charge a higher interest rate.
Basically assuming that you're going to
be cheated, and
you have a monitoring solution. You hire
lawyers to watch over the company to
make sure they're not violating the
constraints. And you as the borrower
end up paying that cost.
Agency costs play out either as higher
interest rates for companies where you
perceive more agency costs,
or as more monitoring costs, in which
case you as the borrower pay the cost.
So, as you look at companies, one of the
things you're going to ask is,
how big are the agency problems at this
company? And the best way to answer that
is if I lend money to this company,
would I be able to sleep at night?
What are the things that make me worry?
So, here are the things we know happen
in practice. We know that lenders like
to lend money on physical assets more
than things they can't see. For whatever
reason, real estate kind of blows
lenders' minds. They lend far too much
money because they can see the building
right there.
But you take a technology company, the
value is coming from a patent, they
start to get a little more wary because
they say, "I can't see it. I don't know
much about technology. You claim to be
an AI company, but I'm not even sure
what that means."
You're going to see the agency problems
actually vary across companies. And
again, using that, I want to think about
three groups of companies, and I want
you to tell me, as a lender, where you
worry the most, because those are the
places where you're going to see the
biggest agency costs, and potentially
the biggest cost to borrow. A technology
firm.
You can see already why as a lender
you're worried. You lend money to
Google. This is at Google campus. Looks
like people are playing all the time.
There's a little slide in the Who does
that? Is that your bank loan doing it?
Right?
Already you can see if a technology
company borrows, the banker is going to
be in there and say, "No, no, no, no
slides in this building. No.
You can't have, you know, free kombucha
coming out of the wall. Now, people are
going to get drunk on kombucha.
As a technology firm, you can see why
both sides are more wary because of
that.
If you're lending to a large, regulated
utility like Con
What makes you sleep well at night as a
lender?
What's the asset of a regulated utility?
Is there a usually a monopoly, they can
sell at a price that is going to cover
their costs.
And then restricted from investing in
other stuff. They can't start an AI
company or a software company. The
things you worry about as a lender
kindly go off, which is one reason
utilities have the highest debt ratios
among any industry group in the market
outside of financial service companies.
You because as a lender you can lend
money to utility get to a 60, 70, 75%
debt ratio and not worry.
And finally, as I said, real estate
historically
has carried immense amounts of debt.
Part of the reason is the value of real
estate by itself historically has not
been that volatile. We look at the total
value of real estate. It goes up by 5%,
drops by 5%, but a 5% drop or 10% drop
in real estate can be
a calamity if you're an equity investor.
You borrowed 90%
of the property value.
I think that going forward real estate
lending should be much more limited. You
shouldn't be lending up to 90% because
real estate values have become more
volatile over the last 20 years. They've
cat caught some of the financial market
disease and have become more volatile.
Perhaps because the investors in real
estate now are the same investors in
equity.
BlackRock is the largest single investor
in real estate. That's going to play out
in real estate become more volatile. But
so far at least lenders have kind of
held back and been willing to live with
the agency problems because they say
it's a building, I can sell it. It's
it's false promise actually because you
as a banker have to liquidate a property
to get your money back, you've already
lost the game.
But you can see why agency costs are
going to be different across companies.
And finally, every time you borrow money
you're giving up some future
flexibility.
So if you're a company that values that
flexibility to be able to do things at
the drop of a hat, how much has Meta
spent on AI?
65 billion, something like that? There
is zero chance they'd have been able to
do that if they'd been a company with a
hundred billion dollars in debt. There'd
have been covenants restrictions saying
you can't throw your money in.
Which might have helped us with the
metaverse fiasco, but you can see why
technology companies don't like to get
their hands tied.
That loss of flexibility is going to
vary the effect of that loss is going to
vary across companies. And companies
that value being able to do things
quickly,
change their business models, should
borrow less than companies that are
fairly set in what their future will
look like.
So that's the trade-off and the question
is do companies actually look at this
trade-off?
The answer can can come from surveying
CFOs and what they look at
when they look at whether to borrow
money. So this is not meant to be the
right answers. This is what CFOs claim
they prioritize when they decide how
much to borrow.
First is maintaining financial
flexibility is at the top of the list.
Second, ensure long-term survival. Think
of that as expected bankruptcy costs in
there.
Maintaining predictable source of funds,
maximize stock price, maintain
independence, maintain a high debt
rating.
And they claim that keeping
comparability with the peer group is way
down the list. I think they're lying.
But that's what they claim.
But take a look at the top, flexibility
and survival, right?
Cuz I'm going to show you the trade-off
and I wanted you to start thinking about
this trade-off as you look at your
company.
So go back and look at your company,
took a look at the country, the marginal
tax rate. There is a table there of tax
rates by country. Look at the tax
benefits. If you have a money losing
company, which you should because I told
you not to pick a money losing company,
already the game is done, right?
What's the tax benefit of borrowing
money if you're a money losing company?
Zero. You shouldn't be borrowing money.
Your optimal debt mix then should be to
not borrow money. The fact that they
have debt can get in the way of that,
but that's the tax benefit.
Second on the added discipline, look at
whether they're a mature company or a
growing company. If you're a mature
company, all equity funded, lots of
earnings and cash flows, may maybe
maintaining that discipline argument
will work.
On the bankruptcy costs, look at the
stability of earnings in your company.
Look at over history. I mean, I I'm
going to be in
Argentina this Friday and I was trying
to find a nice stable Argentine company.
You know what they done?
I said, let me pick the electric
company, regulated utility in Buenos
Aires. You look at the history, this is
a fiasco waiting to happen.
Cuz your country and currency risk
playing out even in the most mature
companies.
Which means if you're an Argentine
company, you probably shouldn't even try
to borrow money in the first place cuz
you already have enough risk to deal
with without the debt added to the mix.
Also look at whether your company is
high or low indirect bank. It's
completely subjective, but the best
thing to do is if I were a customer of
this company,
would the fact that they were low rating
stop me from buying it? Probably not
with DoorDash.
As long as that dinner is ready for me
in 30 minutes, I don't care if DoorDash
goes bankrupt 45 minutes from now. No, I
just need to collect. I think I might be
okay even if they go bankrupt before 30
minutes because I think the restaurant
has to start preparing the food the
minute the order goes through.
So in some companies you can say not a
big deal. Other companies, much more of
an issue.
Agency costs again put yourself in the
shoes of a lender looking at this
company saying, would I be worried if I
lent money to the company? And the
answer is yes, there is an agency
problem, which means you should borrow
less money. It's a completely subjective
trade-off, but it's a trade-off worth
starting your assessment with. Cuz if
nothing else, it'll at least tell you
whether your company should be the type
of company that borrows a lot of money,
borrows less money, or borrows no no
money at all.
So I'm going to do the trade-off for my
company so you can see the game play
out. This is in 2013. If you look at the
tax benefits at that time, Disney had
the highest tax benefit from debt
because it was a US company, 40%
marginal tax rate.
Followed by by a Vale with Vale and and
and and Tata Motors both had a 30 32 33
34% tax rate. And Baidu had a 20. So
base just on the tax rate, I would
expect Baidu to have the least debt and
Disney to have the most debt.
Second, I looked at added discipline.
The one company in this mix where I
worried the most about discipline is
Disney in 2013. There were no activist
investors in the mix. The shareholding
was kind of dispersed.
You could actually argue that this is a
kind of company that could potentially
benefit from having a little more debt.
When you look at expected bankruptcy
costs, now almost all of my companies
have volatile earnings for very
different reasons, right? Baidu
technology firm, Tata Motors
cyclicality, Vale with commodity prices,
and Disney even though it's diversified,
the businesses can can vary. Maybe that
has the lowest volatility, maybe because
they're spread across multiple
businesses. But based again entirely on
bankruptcy costs, you could argue that
indirect bankruptcy costs are likely to
be highest at Tata Motors. It's an
automobile company.
And in terms be
lowest at Disney and Baidu.
Each of these is going to give you a
sense of direction. So looking at the
collective effect is what's going to
lead you there. In terms of agency
costs, highest at Baidu. I have no idea
what a search engine does or what the
money is being spent on.
But if I'm lending to Disney, you can
see it varies across the business. If
I'm lending on the theme parks,
I know exactly what I'm getting. If I'm
lending on Snow White,
I'm not sure what I'm getting, right?
It's a movie, I've no idea what the gate
receipts are. I have to take Disney's
word. So essentially it's going to vary
depending on the business you're lending
against.
And finally, on flexibility, I think
Baidu values flexibility the most
because it's a young company.
In fact, this was before Baidu started
entering new entering new businesses and
trying to do what Alibaba and Tencent
and JD were doing on their platforms.
But this is in 2013. They was they were
already thinking about it. So if you
value flexibility, you should borrow
less. So looking at at the mix, I would
expect Baidu to have the least debt
here.
It's a young firm. It's got the lowest
tax rate, big agency costs.
And Vale and Disney to have more debt
simply because the factor is way more in
favor of debt. So try this for your
company. As I said, won't tell you how
much debt to borrow. Won't say the right
debt ratios, but it'll at least give you
a sense of direction
on where the trade-off will get you.
So
potential tax benefits looking at the
marginal tax rate, the benefits of using
debt, look at who owns the shares, you
know, look at that top 17 shareholder
list that you originally pulled off for
for another reason, take a look at that.
Now, the potential for expected
bankruptcy costs, look at the volatility
of earnings over time. Now, and finally,
agency costs and financial flexibility.
And as I said, just make a judgment.
Will my company be the kind of company
that should borrow a lot or borrow very
little?
And then we'll start to put numbers on
the ratios on on the on how much a lot
is
or how little a little is, right?
Then now I'm going to do a hypothetical,
right?
Do you ever watch the Twilight Zone? One
of my favorite shows. So let's say this
is a Twilight Zone
Twilight Zone episode and you wake up to
a world where there are no taxes.
It's a good world, right?
Let's assume in this world that managers
have shareholder interests at heart and
do do right thing. They might be wrong
in hindsight, but it's not because they
were biased.
Third, no firm in this world ever goes
bankrupt.
Fourth,
when you as equity investors go and
borrow money from lenders, you're honest
about what you borrow. So, if you tell
them you're going to take if you have
risky project, you tell them they have
that you have risky projects. You don't
lie.
And finally, let's assume that every
firm knows its future financing needs
with certainty.
All right, I'm going to take you back to
the trade-off.
Tell me what happens to the trade-off in
this world. Let's start at the top. What
happens to the tax benefits?
Zero. What about added discipline?
What did I say managers do? They do the
right thing. So, zero. What about
expected bankruptcy cost?
Zero.
I agency cost, nobody lies in this
world, so zero. And everybody knows
their future financing needs with
certainty, who needs flexibility? Zero.
Zero, zero, zero, zero, zero. So, how
much should you borrow?
Doesn't matter.
You've just derived corporate finance's
most famous theorem.
The Modigliani-Miller theorem.
Now, we could do an algebraic derivation
of it, but if we do the trade-off, you
can see very quickly
where the Modigliani-Miller theorem is
born. In a world with no taxes, no
default risk, and no agency cost, it
doesn't matter how much you borrow. But,
let me repeat that again. In a world
with no taxes, no default risk, no
agency cost,
it doesn't matter how much you borrow.
It's the most famous theorem in
corporate finance. It's often the only
thing people remember from their
corporate finance class,
and they become bankers and LBO
specialists.
I remember running into a student from
this class very early on, 1990.
He'd been involved in the Federated LBO.
Federated was Bloomingdale's parent
company,
taken over in a LBO. LBO blew up.
Everybody went bankrupt, including the
company that took
And this guy used to work at that
company. So, 2 years later, I ran into
him on Wall Street, and he tells me what
he used to do and where he is now.
And I asked him the question, "Why did
you borrow so much money
on a
on a department store, luxury department
store?
You doesn't make sense." And he said,
"Don't you remember the
Modigliani-Miller theorem?"
I said, "I do, and I'm glad you live in
a world with no taxes,
no default risk. But, remind me again,
what happened to the company you used to
work for?" Without a trace of irony, he
said, "It went bankrupt."
I said, "You might want to go back and
reread the Modigliani-Miller theorem,
because in a world with bankruptcy, it
definitely matters how much you borrow.
This is Modigliani-Miller one.
Modigliani-Miller one is 1958 paper from
which corporate finance was born.
What they introduced was the trade-off.
People don't get that. It's not the
conclusion, it's the trade-off. Because
you take that trade-off,
Modigliani-Miller two, a second paper
they wrote 2 years later, took the
trade-off, took that hypothetical world,
and changed one element. They said,
"What if there are taxes, and we left
all of the other assumptions as is?"
If I introduce taxes into this game, no
bankruptcy cost, no default, no agency
cost, how much should companies borrow?
You get tax benefits, you have no costs,
you should all be at the corner
solution. Everybody should be 100% debt.
Modigliani-Miller two two is base And
then there's a Modigliani-Miller three,
which nobody talks about, which is if
you introduce taxes and bankruptcy cost,
what happens? Well, we're back to
dancing in the middle.
So, let's get this out of the way. We
don't live in a Modigliani-Miller world,
so don't go out and borrow more money
saying it debt doesn't matter. You're
going to go bankrupt, then you're going
to come back to me and say you taught us
the wrong thing.
The Modigliani-Miller world works in a
world with no taxes, no default risk.
It's a very convenient starting point,
because in the Modigliani-Miller world,
the cost of capital will be the same at
every single debt ratio.
That when you borrow money, the benefits
of debt are exactly going to be offset
by the costs.
And that should make sense, right?
Because you take taxes and bankruptcy
risk out of the out of the equation, the
company is the company, the projects are
the projects, the value is the value.
Changing the mix of debt and equity
shouldn't change that value.
Which means the cost of capital you've
computed for your company
No, you didn't, but let's say you had
computed for your company, it would be
the cost of capital at every conceivable
debt ratio.
So, in the Modigliani-Miller world, the
cost of capital is the same at every
debt ratio because you live in a world
with no taxes, no default risk, no
agency cost.
That's all I'm going to say about
Modigliani-Miller, because after that,
what else is there to say? You've got
the trade-off, you can see why the
trade-off works the way In fact, take
the trade-off, introduce small pieces.
What if the government protects you just
against bankruptcy loss? Play it out.
It's an incredibly powerful tool for
recognizing how public policy
can affect debt ratios.
What if governments come in and bail you
out only if you're too large to fail?
What'll happen? Large companies will
then borrow way too much money because
you've essentially taken the bankruptcy
cost out of the mix.
What if the legal system is so slow? I
mean, in India, for instance, it can
take 20 years to get your money back in
court.
Well, guess what? You're going to borrow
too much
and wait for the courts to take 20
years. You effectively have no expected
bankruptcy cost went down.
So, in the Modigliani-Miller world, the
value of a firm will be determined by
the projects it takes,
by the investments, not by the mix of
financing you use. And the cost of
capital will be a straight line at every
debt ratio. And what will happen is both
the cost of equity and the cost of debt
will go up. But,
magically, the weighted average will end
up being roughly the same at
at every debt ratio.
So, I'm going to finish today's class
with
what I call a financing hierarchy. It's
really not what I call it. It's
basically what surveys indicate
companies prefer to use when they
finance their projects. Remember the the
graph I showed you about how companies
around the world fund themselves,
retained earnings, external equity,
external debt.
So, let's go back to the the survey that
looked at what managers value. They
value flexibility, and they value
they they they value survival, value
control.
If you value flexibility and you value
control, control being in the sense you
don't have to answer to somebody. I want
you to think about the type of financing
over which you have the most flexibility
and you have the most control.
You got debt, borrowed money, but then
you got to go to a banker, and what do
you have to do?
You have to explain to them what you're
going to try to do. They can say yes,
they can say no.
You can raise new equity, but then you
got to file a prospectus that tells the
world this is what we're planning to do
with the money.
Or you can use retained earnings, in
which case what do you have to do?
Basically, nothing, right?
Trust us, we know what we're doing.
So, guess what shows up as the number
one choice when companies are asked,
"How would you like to raise money to
fund yourself?" It's no contest.
Retained earnings is the most preferred
choice
for every company that goes out and
says, "Look, we have to raise capital.
What's the best way?" Retained earnings.
Comes with no strings attached,
comes with complete flexibility.
Next in list is straight debt. Straight
debt in the sense there's no attached
options to it.
And then comes convertible debt, then
equity issuances,
preferred stock, and then at the bottom
of the list is convertible preferred
stocks. As you go down the list, you're
going to see more
you know, more control being lost, less
flexibility.
So, when you watch a company issue
security, almost by looking at what type
of security they're issuing, you can get
a sense of how healthy they are.
Okay?
So, let's say you open up a tombstone
ad. You know what a tombstone ad is? A
company raising capital says, "This is
what we're raising. This is the kind of
security we're using." Now, let's say
you look at a tombstone ad, and the
company says, "We're using convertible
preferred
to raise 100 million equity."
You're scraping the bottom of the
barrel, right? GM issued convertible
preferred in 2008 trying to survive.
Companies don't issue convertible
preferred unless they're absolutely
forced to.
So, when you look at your your company,
it's issuing straight debt, it's
probably much healthier than if it's
using equity to raise capital.
It's a signal you're sending about,
"Hey, this is how financially healthy we
are. Look at what we're issuing."
It's called a financing hierarchy, and
you can already see this play out.
And the unsurprising consequence, if you
look just at you know, financing,
internal financing, external financing,
this is at US firms. In every year from
1975 through 2020, the biggest source of
financing at US companies has turned
into internal financing, just retained
earnings. Right?
Then you got new equity and new debt. If
companies raise new capital after
they've gone public, it's almost it's
mostly debt.
And much less likely to be equity.
It's that financing hierarchy playing
out. And then if you start to see
convertible preferred and preferred
stock, you're starting to move down the
hierarchy again.
So again, I'm not saying it's the right
thing to do, but given that managers
control, being flexible, and having
control, it doesn't make sense to It
does make sense to me that there is a
hierarchy of financing.
So, I'm going to stop there. When we
start on Wednesday, we're going to start
by looking at different ways we can come
up with the right mix of debt and equity
for a company.
But, if you get a chance, revisit your
company and take a look at what's on
their balance sheet.
I got a couple of questions regarding
the hotel. Um so, we have to calculate
the
uh
the return on capital by ourselves,
right? Um how can we find the capital?
Like
And about it's like we have to find like
the the market value of capital or
you know
Oh, okay.
Okay. Uh
I What's the company the company that
issues this book?
What do you mean by that?
Um so, I'm not sure whether it's like in
your sheet. There would be like the
category of the company and I'm choosing
between like is it a hotel or is it info
tech?
It's a hotel. It's hotel, right?
Uh and it has rate.
I mean
most of the
Um
marginal tax rate.
Mhm. Marginal tax rate. Because like
what I'm thinking is that why don't we
use the effective tax rate
But, if you look at like in like the
interest I mean interest expense in the
past historical years,
it has never been as high as the
marginal tax rate. It's like always the
effective
What I mean is that basically in the
past five years in the last one year
about tax
I'm not sure what you mean by effective
tax rate being higher than
Marginal tax rate you mean by that? Very
quick.
But, it's not not tax rate. It's tax
rate. Okay. It's basically the marginal
tax rate and the effective tax rate is
an average tax rate across all of your
income. The marginal tax rate is in the
last one.
Yes.
And when I have to do a devaluation,
I would imagine that you would say that
we have to use the marginal tax rate,
right? Cost of debt. Cost of debt.
But, like
like when when I got the EBIT EBIT I
mean EBT earning before tax
Okay, now I got it. All right. Okay.
My last last question.
Um
Like in this slide, I was trying to like
figure out how to
how do we find the probability for the
investor or not that was supplied. And
you mentioned that we have we should
divide the
the the market beta with the R squared.
Um
I mean the standard deviation R squared.
Yeah. But, I I mean what I understand is
why don't we divide it by the R squared
itself?
beta is a standard deviation measure. R
squared goes with variance. I know but
like um when you That's all that
matters, right? R squared goes with
variance.
What is standard deviation? The square
root of the variance. So, if you're
using the square root of the variance in
the R squared, you have to take the
square root of the R squared for the
standard deviation, right?
R squared R squared explains a portion
of the variance.
Beta is a standard deviation measure.
Oh. What's standard deviation? The
square root of the variance, right?
Okay. So, you have to use the square
root of the R squared as well.
Mhm.
But, do I understand But, do I
understand it correctly that the R
squared describe the percentage
of the of variance explained by the
market. But, not the beta. R squared
doesn't doesn't explain the percentage
standard deviation explained by the
beta. Okay. percentage standard
deviation, which is square root of the
variance, you got to use the R squared.
I'm so sorry, but can you like repeat
that?
deviation?
It's just the square root of the
variance. Yeah. Square root. So, beta is
a standard deviation measure.
R squared goes with variance.
But, beta is a standard deviation
measure, you can't use R squared. You
got to use the square root of R squared.
Which is R.
Wha- Why do you say that um beta is What
is It's It's You know the square root of
the equation for beta. Take a look at
the equation. It's correlation divided
by the It's sigma j times rho jm divided
by sigma m. Sigma. Not sigma squared,
right? It's a standard deviation
measure. It's a relative standard
deviation measure.
So, that's why. Thank you so much. Okay.
How are you?
Just a quick question. So, Eli Lilly,
for example, they have a huge thing in
common in
2024. And is that why their
debt or their debt financing
market value that would be so low
because they can finance a lot of the
projects. The problem is they've never
had a high debt ratio. Pharma companies
in general have never had high debt
ratios. Cuz I was just going to say that
if you take a big pharma company, I'm
assuming more stable earnings, you know,
it's a more mature company. Yeah, but
you also have a lot of R&D, right?
Right. Which you don't want I mean, it's
also not physical. Right. What is the
bank lending against, right? Right. You
can say lending against a drug.
I'm spending so much. Okay, then I'm at
your mercy as to what you claim the drug
is making, how much earnings it's
having. You mean I can't see it. It goes
back to this physical versus intangible.
In pharmaceutical companies, you have
blockbuster drugs. You're wearing about
lending something you can't see. Might
be only psychological.
Variance. But, that's a good question.
Thank you so much.
Hey,
uh I have a similar question just what
you said. So, the company I'm doing is
three finance
and it's your company.
I mean, it's actually the one that's
making negative
So, uh I just wanted to ask cuz you said
if you have to calculate that
I thought you said you wanted one
company
that's losing valuation.
So,
wait wait. How do you get the valuation
private
No, no, no. Because you said we're
private equity.
That we we should pick one one one
company Definitely not.
that's making negative money.
Okay.
How do you get the valuation private
In this slide
Yeah. You can ask them how much can you
borrow? The answer can be awful.
Exactly. How much do you pay in
dividends? The answer can be awful.
But, shouldn't it be easier though
because I'm basically all those will be
almost
Right? There's no capital structure in
any of those companies. What do you mean
by no capital structure? No section Oh,
so there's no points to accumulate in
like an analysis. You have to really
nothing to compare to.
money and you can't say I can't borrow
money, right?
So, it becomes an exercise where you you
need to present something that can be
So, basically what you're saying is
change the company fast. Change the
company fast. There's a lot of money
making.
That's
Um or is it
Mhm.